à bedford en estrie la compagnie
bonduelle congèle et en sage des légumes
pour divers marchés elle a lancé au
printemps 2000 21 sous la marque arctic
gardens une gamme de légumes testé pour
les résidus de pesticides
c'est une variable de produits qu'ils
étaient lancés qui représente vraiment
des produits auxquels qu'on a plus le
temps de tester la majorité des
molécules qui existent on utilise leurs
auteurs dans nos cultures dans les
cultures avoisinantes on s'assure que
nous produit dans cette gamme la
convoitise et on les envoie au
laboratoire puis qu'on s'assure qu'il
n'y a pas de présence de peste au delà
de la limite détectables
au canada l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments veillent à la
conformité des produits le but de
l'échantillonnage c'est de s'assurer que
d'écrevisses e trou sur le marché sont
sûres et encore des normes canadiennes
à lagence ont fait annuellement environ
25000 analyse sur 6700 produits de
fruits et légumes sélectionnés de façon
aléatoire
chaque échantillon est contrôlée pour
plus de 600 composer chaque test mesure
plusieurs pesticides ou contaminants
lorsqu un échantillon contient un résidu
de pesticide qui est plus haut que la
limite alors l'échantillon considérés
comme non conforme également le taux de
conformité ou des fruits des légumes
frais ou des pesticides lorsqu'il
présente de surveillance pour lesquelles
je fais partie conjoint est très élevé à
95%
pour les quelque 5 % de produits non
conformes après les analyses de l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments un
protocole est en place lorsqu'ils n'en
ont coûté qui a détecté les résultats
sont envoyés à santé canada une
évaluation des risques et dépendamment
du niveau de risque établi le suivi peut
aller de plus de championnat plus
d'inspections et b même allé jusqu'à
rappel du produit si le niveau si élevé
que vous confirmez que dans les douze
dernières années il n'y a plus de
l'appel de fruits des légumes au pays
de plus selon monsieur l'hymne les
limites maximales établies par santé
canada sont bien en deçà du seuil de
danger pour la santé à l'échelle
mondiale le canada est reconnu comme
mayence tam agroalimentaire extrêmement
robuste avec des règles très strictes et
très clair
mais revenons au slogan testé pour les
résidus de pesticides ça sous-entend
quoi que les produits des compétiteurs
ne sont pas testés
l'épicerie a donc envoyé pour analyse
dans un laboratoire indépendant des
échantillons de quatre marques de petits
pois surgelés une bonne forme biologique
sélection le choix du président et bien
sûr arctic gardens testé pour les
résidus de pesticides
résultat aucun des produits ne contenait
de trace détectable de résidus de
pesticides
n'est pas de traces détectables de
pesticides qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
la concentration du risque du plus beau
c'est
donc non seulement les résidus de
pesticides sont saoulés limite maximale
permise mais il y en a si peu qu'on ne
peut même pas les détecter bonne
nouvelle une entreprise qui veut vendre
produits mais on va tenter d'offrir ce
que le consommateur cherche le
consommateur désire est un produit qui
ne contient pas de traces de résidus de
pesticides
parce que bonduelle offert aux fesses et
le mettre sur l'emballage il n'en devra
pas moins que les autres produits n'en
contiennent pas plus
dans les autres produits qui sont
conventionnés effectivement il n'ya pas
de différence au niveau nutrition il n'y
a pas de différence au niveau de la
qualité des produits mais il peut
effectivement voir utilisation des
pesticides puis asmar on s'assure que
les produits respectent les normes qui
sont mis en place puis ces produits là
pour cette gamme le serein des produits
comme on dit le cul qu'on l'envoie au
laboratoire on voit pas la présence au
programme de le détecter
puisque les normes sont si rigoureuse au
canada ce qui a trait aux traces de
résidus de pesticides
est ce nécessaire de l'indiquer sur les
emballages
pour eux de faire cette annonce là oui
c'est vrai ce qu'ils annoncent cependant
va être quand il y en a pas il y en a
pas l' approche bonduelle me fait un peu
penser
des bouteilles d'eau qui dirait sans
cholestérol
selon pascal thériault l'enjeu auquel
nous ferons face et l'addition des
résidus de pesticides ce qu'on appelle
l'effet cocktail
actuellement les limites sont testés par
produit quand dans les fermes on ingère
des résidus de pesticides
parfois mais on a quelques jamais
l'impact de la somme de ces petits
résidus ici et là donc dans l'ensemble
tout ce qu'on mange de façon
individuelle les pesticides sont bien en
dessous de ce qui la limite maximale
mais il pourrait peut-être qu'il y avoir
des interactions deux différents
produits qui ont jamais été étudié
ensemble je pense que c'est là dessus
que va falloir se pencher dans le futur
comme société